okay hello okay I'm gonna try and make
this video quickly because Shaun of the
Dead is on TV tonight I mean I've got it
on DVD but you know when it's on TV and
it's kind of like to watch it so I'm
gonna watch that as soon as I made this
video so gonna make this video quickly
but the thing is this is gonna be one of
those videos where I really don't know
what I'm gonna talk about a little bit
little bit okay so what I've been doing
recently is I've been playing this
little do-hickey Guitar Hero 3 for the
Nintendo Wii obviously you see that
stickers yay recently whenever I've had
the chance to play guitar hero I have
been playing guitar hero which has made
me feeling a little bit yeah there's
like an extreme amount of product
placement in it I mean the guitar itself
is in the shape of a Gibson Les Paul and
it's got Gibson written on the top and
all the guitars you can get in the game
are Gibson guitars or companies owned by
Gibson that you can get like a guitar
called the Fat Boy which kind of looks
like a Stratocaster but not really and
there's one bit in the game which it's
it just really made me cringe when there
are these two girls that come out with
brown sugar one well written on their
tops like from the Linx adverts the Linx
adverts which sound even on anymore by
the way as anyone
it's that Nyko are pretty much amazing
at the moment they've brought out their
Wii zapper which looks like an actual
gun which looks pretty much amazing same
as the Weezer who is kind of iffy
they've also released details about
their Wireless and nunchuck that's a
nunchuck if you don't know a nunchuck is
touches the bottom of the Wii Remote
which is kind of disappointing because I
like the one I had to use to like
strangle people I mean this wire is
pretty much long enough though okay it's
kind of cool that my friends is a Wii
condom and as well as 9ko bringing out
their gun thing and their Wireless
nunchuck they've also brought out a
guitar for Guitar Hero which is in the
shape of a Fender Telecaster which looks
absolutely lush because they're like one
of my favorite kinds of guitars so Nyko
are just being pretty much amazing for
anybody who owns a Wii at the moment
Charles is cool like does product
placement for nyko what the hell right
right stop talking about computer games
I want to show you this this is my
little black book thingy
it's basically like a little scrapbook
thing so that's me looking really
attractive and yes I am worried charlie
is so cool like it hat there because I'm
extremely cool charlie loves to party
there's some wrapping paper because I
got this little book for Christmas and
that's the wrapping paper it came in
possibly if anyone can tell me what this
is then please do because I wrote
seriously what the hell is it and where
can I get more we've got the bunny here
from cute with Chris and that's like a
Pikachu ghost there's me as a baby
Yorkshire Tea yeah your cutie oh my god
Charles is so cool like this product
placement for Yorkshire tea that there
is a tube ticket from the September 15th
YouTube gathering I bought that when I
was with Mars daya hello miles
is Mario I have a sticker here that says
sliver and so I put in on the end get it
get it get it this is thanks to my
newfound love of Harry Potter this guy
here is a drawing I did like ages ago
that's the skull kid from Majora's Mask
more got tire sticker and tendo the we
over there I also have a photo of some
garlic bread if you know who that guy is
there then you are really really cool I
wrote Hitler's mustache minus 250 points
but I'm not going to talk about nerimon
because I always talk about nerimon the
fact is and it's ends up appearing and
like loads of my videos recently and he
doesn't need more any more exposure
because he got featured on the bloody
global sites owl don't go and check out
nerimon whatever you do do not go and
check out nerimon and this is the page
in one at the moment look it's me as a
baby me the baby there's a picture of me
there when I was in the paper
is a joke how does Charlie get down the
stairs he slides down the Bernard
banana stirs see it's more funny because
Charlie is actually a monkey Zelda Mario
karts a drawing that my friend Mullane
did it's got lots and lots and lots of
lots of pages and I've done one two
three four five six seven eight and I'm
doing nine and ten it's kind of making
slow progress but I am doing it which is
I am impressed by because I always start
love these little project things and I
never do them there's so much random
stuff in here I have decided to post
this video as a response to
Haley's fiveawesomegirls video Kaylee
basically said that you want responses
so here's a response Haley
Kaylee check them out and also if you
haven't checked out five awesome girls
yet then do this is my sofa right fine
goodbye buying a pike a pie I'm gonna
kill him